i'm michael stipe
i'm
the author of the hot chocolate graphql
libraryfor.net
and today i want to talk about graphql
observability
actually this talk has
just
just very few slides
because what i want to do
is unpack
problems that we are facing
in graphql libraries when we put them to
production
so we are going to
dig into
a graphql service
and uh trying to explore what the issues
with it with the servicer
and how we can fix them and how we can
make them visible
so when the torx name is here graphical
observability that is
actually is the aim where we want to be
at the end of this talk
so why graphical observability
so graphql has some unique challenges i
would say
when you want to
make
performance impact visible
to the developers
and that has to do with its nature
like if we look at this simple graphical
query it's actually
when i explain graphql getting started
to graphically i always start
with this slide
or it's always at the very beginning
and i tell people this is a hello world
of graphql
and it essentially asks here for
the name of the currently signed in user
and if we send something like this to
our graph cursor we
get exactly what we asked for i mean
that's a great thing with graphql right
but it's also one of the challenges
because a user
then
can just ask for more data
and that means that the
that i don't really know the performance
characteristics
of my back end
so how do i determine if everything
goes right
if my service performs well
or
if the front-end developers now
created queries that are so huge that i
really have an impact on my back end
and since the graphql we
can really dig deep we could get into
related objects and so on and so forth
really could create huge query trees
so typically and that is
how many people start with graphql
is to put a thin layer of graphql over
there business layers
if we look at that might be easy to
figure out where performance issues are
because graphql is very thin
we just have this business layer we
should know what we are talking about
but in many setups graphql is actually
deployed like
this where we have microservice beneath
it
rest services
these rest services then again use
databases
use other services this could be a huge
tree
so selecting just fields in my query
then poses a
risk or a challenge to me because i
don't really know how many systems are
impacted my cr by my queries
and another thing
how do i actually know
what queries my front end developers are
doing with my system how do i find that
out
so the big question is then
how do we find
production issues
because typically it's like this you
deploy to your service
and then it's done for you and then
somebody comes along
and asks maybe did you deploy something
new
why
because something is not behaving as
before
maybe we are having issues things are
getting slower
and this is actually where we
can start in a little
exploration
let's say we have
a little application let me just start
it
i have your visual studio code
and that is actually my back end
let me just start it up
and we are not just looking from the
back end
at it first
let's actually look at the application
so this our back end let me just clear
that here
and then we that comes actually with the
front end
and that's where the problems actually
always
begin
okay let me refresh that so that's my
front-end application
let's redo that
so server's warmed up
it actually performs very well
but let's say my
that the users reported performance
issues and maybe also
some
system administrator told us about
huge pressure on our system
so how would we approach this find out
what is wrong with our system because
when i refresh that
that application here it
it performs very well 170 milliseconds
for getting all this data that we see
here
and
i mean we could try and um
go to another page but it
kind of performs very very well
so typically that's where we start
yeah let's let's let's have a look at
the locks or let's have a look at our
locks our locks we always post to the
console
like that's often how projects start
and then we can already see yeah that's
that's quite a lot of
stuff here
so let's clear that
maybe
and then have a look
at the very simple
request
so let's go maybe on the bit bitcoin
here that's our cryptocurrency a single
cryptocurrency and let's have a look
what is being locked
so we again can see that the request
times yeah they're very
170 to
350 milliseconds
so there is a variance but it's actually
it doesn't feel so bad
and actually there's no lock because
in our application we are using a store
that means we are caching the objects
that's why my local application actually
performs so well
so let's refresh that so my store is
destroyed and it just patches all the
object that i need and that now for just
this single page
i can already see that there there is a
lot going on like
holy
so much sql
you can see
we are selecting here the users
maybe a specific user then we are
getting uh the the bitcoin
base data we are getting like price data
and actually we are getting a lot of
price data oh no just a single one here
then we are getting
[Music]
watch list
and you can see there there's a lot
going on
but then we are also doing http calls
here we're going to a rest service
and we're getting the price for our
bitcoin here
and then there's more sql
okay that's that's that's already an
indicator where we could say that that
that doesn't feel right
but we actually have no clue at this
point
but a lot of applications that
i also
came to
experience in production at projects
they just have logging
and it's very difficult to understand
how your system works from a logging
standpoint
because you have this
huge
data input that you have to sift through
i mean there are tools and console
logging is maybe not the best approach
to do it but it's a good enough approach
on my local system
okay so how would i
go in graphql about that
so
when people start with graphql they
always hear about something that that is
called apollo tracing
and that is a more
graphql way to look at performance data
of our resolvers because i saw there's a
lot going on here but where is that
actually going on and which query is
causing this
so what we could do
and this is also still a very naive way
in looking at that
we could maybe just grab our graph code
query here
let me just
go at that
let's refresh that
now we get our graphql query here we
we could just copy it copy the value
then go into our graphql id of choice
and have a look at it
okay
so this is actually the the data that
the client requests from
from our back end when it starts you can
see so this is a view container query
here that's the name of our operation
it's good to know we keep that in mind
and then you can see we have a lot of
fragments here and each fragments
fetches a certain amount of data like
here's some base data description
then we have here the price data we are
getting
then we are actually
actually fetching for our chart we are
fetching the change
data so the price price points in
the historic price points over the day
and there's more price data we are
actually fetching here
so we can just run that also here again
our back end but it dies
ah yeah it dies because it needs a
variable here
we also can just grab that from our
from our request here just
copy
and paste
into our variables and then we can
actually run it
and we get the data
let's rerun it and you can see it
but here for the first time can see a
variance it's 900 milliseconds to 200
milliseconds
so there is variance
but if you typically debug that if
you're in the range of 100 to 200
milliseconds you will not see a problem
here
locally because you're just running this
single instance
that's why
when you when you publish such a thing
to production you actually are surprised
then that your system maybe goes down
okay
let's have a look at the
at
at what we can do in graphql to make it
a bit more visible
uh what's going on and i said there's
something called apollo tracing
that's that's a naive approach
but you will get an idea of how your
resolvers perform actually
so we can go in here into our graphql
server
and without chocolate we can just chain
in our configuration
so this add graphql server is actually
where our server configuration starts
and then we can just chain in
so in this instance we are training in
add apollo tracing
um and then we say always
always trace it's not a good idea
actually you will see because if you
always produce traces you will waste a
lot of performance
and that's exactly what we don't want to
do
but it's a good way to debug locally a
bit
okay
so if we run that
we actually get now this extra data down
here
you can see
we should
we don't
maybe
let me check
this can be because in banana cake but
we actually don't support it
so let's go to playground
and put it in here
there is also a service called apollo
studio
which lets you essentially
send these
tracing data to it
okay
do we are we connected yes
okay again we post our
query in here
and then
we're gonna analyze it
so up so playground now has um
has down
let me get the way has down here this
tracing
blade
and if we run that query you can see we
get some
performance inside here
and if we look at that we actually it
doesn't look so bad like we have this
price change is 62 milliseconds
and this history okay we know it goes to
rest in point 215 milliseconds
so we get an idea
over our resolvers here but we don't
actually get real insights
and that is the problem with um with the
approach of logging and tracing when you
look at it isolated
let me go back to my slides
okay
why i unpack that in this way
is actually
that we don't don't really get insights
in our system and it's everything is
very isolated we cannot really see
what's going on we maybe see there is an
issue we have this variance
we could go now through the code we
could look at the resolvers what are
they doing where are these things um
where
where are these
sql queries caused and so on and so
forth but it can be very very difficult
to see the relation between distributed
systems
so this is where this concept of
observability comes in
and that is essentially
the the ability to measure how healthy
and how performant your system is
by collecting data by looking at the at
the tracing data at the logging data at
the metrics and so
and so forth
so observability if you go two or three
years back
was very difficult to achieve it was
possible like
i worked at a large project and we built
our own observability providers we
we injected into each uh http request we
injected correlation ids we injected in
into our
messaging systems extra metadata to
trace how the logging flow is and it
took a lot of effort and
there was a single
software engineer just working on that
that thing and it wasn't enough to
have a really
qualitative solution
so over the years
there were a lot of approaches to tackle
this problem
and that's actually where open telemetry
comes in
and starting with dot net six
using open telemetry becomes very very
easy there are a couple of apis now in
dot net
a new activity api where it's easy to
produce traces to use these things that
we call spans
to create them and to
essentially collect
and produce this tracing data
so when we talk about open telemetry
we
have a couple of terms here
like we want to instrument our api
essentially we want to add
special metadata to it
to later
work with that in a
certain tooling that
brings us these observability
concepts
by default open telemetry doesn't
automatically make your system
observable
but it's essentially instrumenting your
apis
and by doing this instrumentation we
then generate data
that we can use
that we can collect
to ship to an actual
back end we call that export and these
are actually the terms that are
important we instrument we generate the
data we collect it and then we ship it
to a tool there are a lot of tools out
there we are using today elastic
which is very good but there are others
that are also very good like jager maybe
you heard of it
or honeycomb
and so
forth
so we also
talk about melt when we talk about open
telemetry
and melt if you hear it you think what's
that
it actually just means metrics events
logs and telemetry
because these four things
make our system observable
so what are metrics metrics are things
that we collect maybe the
the cpu usage of your system could be a
metric
how much memory you are using how often
your garbage collector is running there
are metrics
and a lot of these metrics microsoft
already implemented their default
metrics about http about asp.net core
about garbage collection and stuff like
that
then we have events
that is essentially when something
happens on your system
so um
i actually wrote a i read a good um
article about that
and the lady explaining that there i
said okay events you essentially can
think of a vending machine
where you push a button
and then something comes out that could
be an event
and when we talk about about that in an
open telemetry context we often
annotate these events with metadata and
then you can use these metadata and
these events
to um
[Music]
to analyze that in an observability
concept context and we will have a look
at that how we can do that in
in elastic
oh
yeah and the the locks essentially
is just the standard locks that you had
before
just that we now
with the traces
can put into spans and can put into
context so you still have your locks
and combined with the traces the traces
are these spans that we can put
around our more important things we we
will have a look at that what that means
to measure what's happening between
systems
so typically
when we look at our app
we have some kind of an api that we use
to instrument our application
then we have the open telemetry sdk
and that is processing
these events logs that we get here and
then we have something called an
exporter
that will ship these
these data somewhere like we could have
a jaeger exporter and then locally look
at these things
or we could have
like an additional service an open 12v3
collector and if you're doing telemetry
at scale you will actually um use an
open telemetry collector because you can
better
arrange how much
collector instances
you want to better distribute the
performance that this takes because also
instrumenting your services doesn't come
free
so in a typical typical
kubernetes cluster you might have two
collectors or so
and then you essentially offload the
processing to the collector instead
instead of each of your applications
and then this collector has again also
an exporter maybe
and can export the data or push the data
to a telemetry backend
in our setup we will use their elastic
apm for observability
so let's go a bit in our code and
get more insights in our system
just by the way so i put here
very naively
apollo tracing always and don't do that
um because it adds a huge
payload to your system
so if you want to use a puller tracing
tooling
then
set it to on demand and
that means you essentially can pass in a
header i think it was x x dash tracing
and then ask for telemetry data
also this you should secure that
and only allow certain users to ask for
that data otherwise you also open
with apollo tracing some security risks
that somebody could use that
to bring your system down
like because you're producing that
a lot of data and sending it down as the
json
okay
so let's put open telemetry into our
system
so the first thing i already put some
libraries in here and at the moment
you can see that like my open telemetry
versions are crc versions here and
picked
because it's an ongoing project we
started to see
um
the abilities in dot net six
uh and you can see it's now in the least
candidate uh staged uh so it's getting
more mature but it's new
right
and i also put these open cinema 3 apis
already in here
and you really need to know which
versions at the moment go together
still if you're starting with this i
mean we are using that already at scale
because we thought
when at our projects where we
started with elastic should we go for
the native elastic apis
that are available or should we invest
already in open telemetry and since it's
a new project we went with open
telemetry
because that is a more
standardized way and allows me later if
i want to move away from elastic to
jager or use different tooling
additionally
to produce the data for it and not be
tied into elastic itself so if you have
a new project definitely start with
telemetry if you're already using a
proprietary apis
you can wait a bit
but you will see it will give us a lot
of insights here
okay
so the second thing for hot chocolate i
put in was the hot chocolate diagnostic
and that essentially
gives us insights into the hot chocolate
in inner workings
essentially produces open telemetry data
for
a graphql
and
down here you see this open terminatory
installation instrumentation asp.net
core and http
these two providers will give us
telemetry events from the asp.net core
engine and also from the http client
we will see in a second what that means
so the first thing that we actually have
to do with our api
is to declare what
the metadata about our api
let me put that up here
so
we would use something called the
resource builder
to essentially
um tell open telemetry what services did
what service it is you can see my
service we call it coin api because it's
about cryptocurrencies then we have a
namespace here which i can use for
filtering later
and i'm telling it it's version two
i also
can
provide here some
things about the environment for
instance this is a development
environment here
and
i'm using the
net sdk
and i can provide some versioning here
so this is some metadata what you can
filter on
in the open telemetry context later
the second thing is
i need to put some instrumentation
services in here
let's do that
so
let's first put the tracing in so at
open telemetry tracing i said there are
four parts to open telemetry this is the
tracing part and you can see
i added here http client instrumentation
asp.net core instrumentation and hot
chocolate instrumentation
the the second thing is i'm using an
otlp exporter so what is that
otlp stands for open telemetry
um protocol um
and
it allows me to push to an open
telemetry collector
so typically
you would
let me just uh open this
you would send them an open geometry
collector and so forth
i'm not doing that here because it's
more work
so this is for instance you have such a
yummy file where you can configure your
open telemetry
collector and can tell it essentially
essentially that it shall push the data
to elastic
so we would put here some
authentication data in so that it can
can communicate with elastic
and there is also from elastic like this
docker compose file
which essentially gives you a local
elastic cluster
setup already with the open telemetry
collector so it's quite
um easy to set it up
but for a demo it's a it creates a lot
of overhead so
what i did
and don't do it in your production
system
is i push directly to elastic
here because elastic actually
understands the otlp protocol it's the
same protocol that the collector has
right
but it's um if you want to have a really
performant infrastructure and reliable
infrastructure go with the collectors
okay so the second thing we do
is we add the metrics
and at the moment we don't have any hot
chocolate metrics
um but you can put in your own metrics
that you want to collect about hot
chocolate and we will have a look at
that
okay again we have the http metrics the
asp.net core metrics
and we push it to the same
same cluster
so with this we actually
put everything in there's one more thing
so we are we are telling here our system
to collect
hot chocolate instrumentation events
but we still have to
tell hot chocolate that it should
produce these events so we say add
instrumentation
and
now the execution engine will actually
produces
these events because we didn't want to
put them in by default because as i said
they have some performance impact
okay let's run that
and then produce some calls
i'm just executing this a couple of
times
so we get some data
and then we are going to elastic
so my so elastic
starts around at
40 dollars just if you're interested
what i have here is a 40 cluster
but as i said you could also run it
locally it's open source
they have a dual license
that's something new
because
amazon started stealing their stuff
and but it's essentially you can you can
run it for free
or in the cloud
okay so here's my ndc demo cluster let's
go in that
oh conference connection so and
most people when i tell them
elastic and observability there what
elastics is for searching it is for
searching but the observability is built
essentially on the um
on the elasticsearch engine
so let's go in the observability here
and you can see
i already have some lock rating here
there are no metrics yet that are
interesting for me so
but i can see that the apm has already
some throughput data
and what we are going to look at is now
the metric side
uh the tracing side which is down here
in the apm level
i can go here and have already a look
i can see there's my coin api and
there's a price api the price api is
actually my
price data the rest course that we did i
also instrumented that
so the system knows my that there is a
price api
i can before we go in the tracing i
actually can have a look at the service
map
so because i produced
traces here elastic was
able to identify dependencies between my
services because it traces the trace it
traces
the logs
um between the services essentially by
injecting um correlation ids into the
http request and so forth and and so on
and also it can trace like you can see
okay the price api user postgres
sql database so it knows a bit about my
setup here just from looking at these
traces
[Music]
and now i can essentially drill into
that
so let's go for the coin api here
and you can see here i have my
environment so i can filter that to the
development environment and then i can
see here this graphql
which is not ideal
because we talked about graphql having
so much
having so much variance because the user
can actually send any query to my
endpoint and now
any graphql query actually
is tracked under the same endpoint this
is not good this is a specific problem
that we now have because we are using
the http
uh telemetry together with graphql
i can see there's a query but for
filtering and looking at these things
it's actually not good how we organize
this
so there is a way around that to make
that better
so before we go into
the telemetry data here let's just fix
that up go back to our service
and put some options into here so we can
say
i want to
rewrite my telemetry events
and it's
essentially
i want to rename
the root activity
and i show you in a second why
and also um
include the graphql document so by
default we don't do that
you could choose to do that only on
maybe your testing environments because
it's an extra payload that will send the
whole graphql query to the telemetry
background
or it doesn't have such an impact you
don't have that scale then you just can
include it always okay so i did these
two things
but still i don't want to waste so much
time there it's not an ideal setup
so in open telemetry we can actually
enrich the events that we are sending to
our back end
and we are going to do that here
and we are going to rename
the root level for elastic so that it's
nice and
tidy in our dashboard
so this actually works through something
that we call an activity enricher
so we say custom
activity and
david t and
richard.cs
and i already prepared this guy here so
this is an
activity enricher it essentially
inherits from activity enricher
and i just generate the constructor here
we don't have to care about what is
being passed in it's essentially the
options and the pool to
efficiently generate strings
okay and then i can override
how these
how these data for my elastic cluster
are being enriched with additional data
for instance i can say create the root
activity name here
and
in my case i know i show you why i do
that in a second i'm just saying okay
the root activity name shall be the
display name
and then
we are going to put that in to our
configuration here
and then we re
run the queries a couple of times and
look at the traces
so let's say blur
has singleton
we want the activity enricher here
activity and richer
which
is our custom enricher okay
with that
let's do that again
go to banana cake pop here
and run these queries just just a couple
of times that that we actually
can see them in our system and have
a variance of traces actually
okay
okay go here
we are going back to our coin api
and
let's refresh that and now you can see
that
the traces that we produce
actually have like this format that
looks almost like our query what we we
are not posting the whole query here
because it's a title but we will tell
you the name of the query that our
client application uses and we also will
tell you about the root field this query
uses
okay from this we can then drill in we
down here see the latency distribution
of our event so where are most of the
requests you can see okay some are in
200 milliseconds
this one was when the server was not
warm
was two seconds
and then we have uh here 95 percentile
of the requests essentially in this in
this bucket
okay let me just drill into
some of these
so we can see what really happens here
now this is the graphql
event i can look at the metadata
here i can see the actual uh graphql
query but i also have some other
information like the hash
um like i can see that it's a single
http request it was not batched and
thinks about the transport
and i can also see like my resolvers
we only report the resolvers that
actually do something async so if you
just have a field like a string like a
name of something we will not report it
because it's just data that is useless
but you can already see okay asset by
symbol is a field that cost me 10
milliseconds
then we have this price field
and then you can see here some bad
shapes that will do http requests
you can see there is something going to
the change service here
and each call to this change service
will actually do two database calls
this is the first indicator where we
should say okay
something
may be wrong
but if it's just one call
why not
but then we can see it's actually two
calls in this instance
that are going to the server so it's two
database calls
and that's just
for one asset
so if we go in our client and look at
maybe a list of assets
maybe let's do that
then we get more pressure on our system
so we go here
let's produce a couple of these events
okay so let's go in our
overview
coin api
let's refresh it
and you can see now we we really get all
the insights from our
client now you can see all the queries
that are coming in here's the dashboard
query
and you can see now we have a list and
you can see here every price field
actually calls something
and now you see a lot more database
usage so this might be where our problem
lies with our back end
which then at scale might produce
the problem and you can see there's a
lot of
things going on
and from that we could drill into
our apis i mean this is
really not looking so good and i can see
actually what is being called here i can
look at my http request
and now could have a look at this new
api
so what's being called you can see okay
it's a batched request
so it should be fast we are batching
actually the http request for multiple
cryptocurrencies to this
so actually it should be fast
but then let's have a look at the sql
so first we are just looking at
how many things we have
but then we are doing a percentage
change call here that's good but we're
just getting one item
and you can see
we're doing this again
and we're doing this call again you can
see these chords are repeated so for
each cryptocurrency that we are actually
batching to our downstream service
we are doing again and again this course
and this is
this is something that
where
you couldn't have expected that from the
graphql layer the problem actually is
not in our graphql layer it's actually
in this downstream service that we are
using
where they didn't implement the batching
maybe well so the version two of this
endpoint actually introduced a problem
to our graphql layer
and what we what we saw in projects
where we introduced such
observability
you automatically found a lot of issues
even
if you didn't know about them because it
now makes it transparent how these
how are these different distributed
systems work together like the graphql
layer uses some other service down here
maybe you even have another service
under that and now you
you see
what these services are doing how they
are communicating
and
what they are doing inefficiently
so we could fix that probably
let's do that quickly
we probably could
in this instance i know i just have to
roll back the api change that the
developer did so i could go in my data
loader that's where we do the batching
and where we'd use the price change
and i just could go for the old api
again
and say let's go
dotnet run
then we could go to our client again
run these a couple of times so that we
get
some new data
okay
so there is one more thing after that
so we could again look at this probably
some of the
things should have changed now let's
look at this lower thing here
and you can see now i'm using my old my
old version of the service and suddenly
i'm just using one database call
so this is how
observability makes it very transpar
transparent or
the combination of open telemetry and
elastic makes it very transparent
um what is going on between my systems
there is so that's something i haven't
set up here
but we are using that actually and that
is machine learning so you can actually
produce
i use machine learning to look at things
that are different
like maybe you're running your system
over a long time and we have these
tracing data and suddenly you do such a
change and now you have multiple more
cores to your downstream services then
elastic can actually send you an email
look
your query now uses a lot more database
connection as before
and then an engineer an engineer could
look at that
before you run into the problem where
the user calls you that the system is
running into timeouts
and that is with um these events it
becomes a lot easier if you're using
something like metrics here
and you can use
custom metrics
and it actually is quite simple to
integrate them also with
with
hot chocolate and
our query engine we have a couple of
things like we have a cost analysis api
so you can
actually use a different execution
pipeline here we could go for the use um
oh actually it's in the default pipeline
um
so you can set the options at request
options
all right
no modify request options
sorry for that
and tell our system
to
analyze the cost of a graphical query
the cost of a graphql query let me just
show you that
and
because we are running out of time
i'm not going to deep into that but it's
a good
way
to actually provide additional metrics
to your system so we could say
complexity
let me just get this here
complexity dot enable
and this will
enable our complexity analysis on
graphql queries we will look at
how the query is structured how many
async fields you have
and essentially generate a number that
describes the weight of this query for
your system
and we could send that as a metric
to your telemetry back end
and then if
the metro if the cost of queries
increases because your developers
and your front end developers are using
more and more fields or
it becomes
more and more complex queries then you
essentially also can put like events on
top of that and see okay that's actually
wrong we need maybe to introduce
something different here
or maybe we have to scale out because
that's our new use case our new normal
and things like that
um so i enabled that
and this would now
write for every query the complexity
into our metadata
um
i just
just to force the error because we don't
have time to actually integrate that let
me
do the max allowed query let me let me
just put it to five
just to cause the error
let's run that
and then you will see what i mean
is it running
okay so if i run that it actually leads
to an error but i what i wanted to show
here is so the execution engine now
weights these queries and it says okay
the the complexity of this query is 135.
and
the the allowed complexity actually is
just to cause this error but this
metric we could now send to elastic
because we set enable complexity here
and then we could use that to weight our
query
and use machine learning to find out if
a query goes out of range should be
allowed or things like that
in order to do that
we would use the new api.net so it's
called meter
i'm not integrating that now but just to
give you a hint where you can look
and you can give a meter a name like we
could call this foo dot bar like we
always have these dot notation
and you also could give it a version
and then we could
the version is always good because if
you
change the structure of it over time and
then you could essentially create
counters or
produce
some
metric data and this
would now be automatically integrated
because we could
then take this key here
and just tell our metrics here
that we are adding
instrumentation and that we want to live
listen to that specific
meter
so this is how you could
integrate even
more into your
observability solution
we are almost
we are at the end of our talk here
this is my twitter handle if you want to
connect
hot chocolate repositories here um so
all the code
you will find there
if you have questions i'm available you
can also come afterwards to me and if
you want to have a chat
yeah if you like our project would be
great
if you star it if you don't it's also
okay
questions
okay that was a quick dive into
the problems that you could face
when you put graphical production and
how you can solve the issues that you
are facing there
okay